television for serious readers next Doug
Casey sits down with book TV to talk
about politics and economics from
Freedom Fest an annual libertarian
conference then at 7:30 firefighter
Jason Ramos recalls his life as a smoke
jumper
battling wildfires from above Chelsea
Clinton highlights some young people
from around the world who are having a
great impact on their communities at
9:00 p.m. Eastern and on afterwards at
10:00 p.m. Fox News host Bill O'Reilly
discusses the Reagan presidency after
the assassination attempt with bay
buchanan and at 11:00 Eastern Daymond
Tweedy takes a look at race in America
through the lens of his experience as an
african-american doctor that all happens
next on c-span two's book TV now first
up is political contrarian Doug Casey
and now joining us on book TV is Doug
Casey
mr. Casey what do you do for a living
what do I do for a living
well I wear a number of hats actually
venture capitalist publisher and author
and you have my last book in your hand
which I'm very pleased to see has been
properly annotated and we will get to
that in just a minute how did you get
into the businesses that you are in well
like many things that's a question of
taking a right turn at a corner instead
of a left turn so a lot of these things
are accidental but when I was a kid the
first thing I wanted to be was a
paleontologist
it's all about dinosaurs and that led me
to an interest in geology later on I
wanted to make some money so I started
studying economics I put them together I
got into the mining business and mining
finance but for many years have kept up
an interest in many different subjects
because if you're going to be an
effective venture capitalist it's good
to know as much as you possibly can
about as many different subjects as you
possibly can
so I guess that sums it up when we think
of venture capitalists we often think of
Silicon Valley and and technology I'm a
technophile but when it comes to using a
computer you can't kiss all the girls so
I use my computer mainly as an IBM
Selectric look-alike and something to
access the Internet
I probably use five tenths of one
percent of its capabilities they
generous so that's not the areas that I
get into have you been successful I
think I have because if I retired today
and I don't want to because I want to
have to fill my idle hours with
something I wouldn't have to work again
for several lifetimes but I'm not money
motivated money is extremely important
but it's not the most important thing in
the world it's money is something that
allows you to put the theory whatever
your theory is into practice and one of
the problems with a lot of libertarians
and there may be some listening to
c-span I don't know is that they tend to
be penniless intellectuals in other
words they all hate Karl Marx but
they're like Karl Marx because this is
Mark said to Karl one time Karl stop
writing about capital and earn some of
it so this is a big problem
are you a libertarian well I'm more than
a libertarian actually my pilgrims
progress politically I started out as a
liberal when I was about 8 years old I
asked my mother to write a letter to
President Eisenhower to do something
about all those poor black people living
in the ghetto I lived in Chicago at the
time
and then I became a conservative after I
read Barry Goldwater's great book the
that he call that conscience of a
conservative the conscience of a
conservative and then my next step was I
was about 23 and I read Ayn Rand's book
the virtue of selfishness and I thought
I was an Objectivist I didn't realize at
the time it was actually a religion in
disguise although I'm a big fan of a and
ran nonetheless and then I read another
book called the market for liberty which
convinced me that I was an anarchist so
like many of the people at this
convention I don't believe that
government serves a useful purpose or
even has a right to exist so the answer
your question is I'm an
anarcho-capitalist right on the money is
your latest book yes what kind of an arc
oh and article capitalism is reflected
in this part
well it is exactly that
this is primarily a financial book and I
talk about what's going on in the world
for the point of view that most of the
bad things in the world are caused by
the state as an institution but the good
news the good news is that the state
destroys an immense amount of capital
and everything else but at the same time
it creates distortions in the
marketplace and these distortions are
things that speculators can capitalize
on so from the point of view of society
the government is a terrible thing but
from my point of view as a speculator
it's a good thing from your book page to
93 people that often gush about what a
wonderful thing the Constitution is but
I've always suspected that US and world
history would be different and better if
those delegates had done as they were
told and just smoothed over the rough
spots in the Articles rather than
replace them with the Constitution yes
yes I believe that it's an accurate
statement and I'll explain why most
people especially conservatives think
the Constitution is a
written on gold leaf and was handed down
by a higher power I think that the
Constitutional Convention of 1789 was
actually what amounts to a coup the
delegates that went to the Philadelphia
to write the Constitution were
authorized only to make certain
modifications to the Articles of
Confederation but they changed
everything now saying that of
constitutions that exist in the world
today the US Constitution is still the
best Constitution but I think we would
have been better off if these 13 states
had stayed 13 states instead of coming
together in a federal government so well
put it put it put it that way of course
the whole thing about the Constitution
is meaningless because it's a dead
letter
nobody observes the Constitution if you
read the Constitution you find that it's
been interpreted part of existence even
the Bill of Rights is meaningless
today every segment in the Bill of
Rights lip service at most so I make a
point about the fact that the country
would have been better if it had never
come together as the US would have
stayed independent states but
the Constitution today is meaningless
anyway Doug Casey as a business person
how much involvement with government do
you have in your daily work well I try
to have as little as possible with the
US government but my hobby for the last
thirty years has been going to
third-world countries often military
dictatorships and things like that and
talking to the guys that run the country
giving them a radical program to take
their place off the bottom of the totem
pole and turn it into a new Singapore on
steroids which is possible so I've had
some wonderful adventures doing that in
fact just last month I spent 10 days in
the Islamic Republic of Mauritania
talking to the government and rich guys
and centers of influence about a slight
modification to my usual plan making it
into a free State will I succeed well I
haven't so far like I said this is a
hobby but so I use government's don't
like them try to stay away from the US
government because the US government is
genuinely dangerous but yeah that's what
I do if you had to define the US
government and what you think its
purpose should be what what is that
definition
well the US government is the most
conservative institution on the face of
the planet at this point
it wants to the US government is like
any organization whether we're talking
about a company or an NGO or or an
individual or to me before that matter
and its first directive its prime
directive is survive and like any
bureaucracy
in order to survive it has to grow and
become more powerful and this is what
the US government has done it's taken
over American society everybody looks to
the US government to be a part of copia
to be a cure-all for everything that
ails us and what they're doing is
they're looking to a cancer to cure
other diseases it's completely insane
there's nothing that the US government
does that the market would not do
cheaper and better and most importantly
without coercion and that's what the
guess what government is all about
multisim said the power of the state
comes out of the barrel of a gun and I
don't think that's the proper way for
free people to relate to each other what
do you think about the warren buffett's
and Bill Gates of the world who are
giving away their personal for
I think they're idiot savants they're
obviously geniuses
I mean Buffett when it comes to
investing a genius and gates of what he
did a genius same can be said about Ted
Turner for what he did but just because
these people are superb in one area
doesn't mean that their thoughts of
wisdom and it's I think it's insane
they're giving away their fortunes to
these NGOs and charities because
reasonably familiar with charities in
the way they work and they dissipate
this capital that's been created and
oftentimes the money that is given to
people to make the these to make gates
and Buffett me thousands of other people
I can make it's it's for the good of the
donor to make them feel good or to help
them compensate for their past sins in
their own mind but the people that get
the money its unearned money and it
tends to cement them to the bottom of
society but most of the charity's money
goes to fund rating raising parties and
paying fat salaries to the pipes that
work for NGOs so no I think it's foolish
if Buffett really wanted to help the
people of the world he'd just continue
what he's doing forever growing capital
because the way we all become wealthier
the world the world becomes wealthier is
by increasing the amount of capital in
the world not by pissing it away in
dribs and drabs the people that haven't
earned it
who is Louis James and how is this book
structure Louie works for Casey research
and he's our mining analyst but like any
good financial analyst he's also a
broad-ranging intellectual so he knows
the right questions to ask and how did
you structure this book you know the
form of interviews instead of chapters
we did interviews so ask me a question
and I'll give you an answer pretty much
like what we're doing now except there
is unvarying
topics so I cover the waterfront from
Africa to I don't know what begins with
the Z that's in there but probably
something Zimbabwe part of Africa yes
I'll be going to I've spent a lot of
time in Zimbabwe my first book and the
international man was the largest
selling book in the history of Rhodesia
which is what Zimbabwe used to be and I
went there a number of times during the
war in the 70s found a publisher and
Salisbury it's now called Harare and
everybody bought the book because it was
a book about how to make the most year
personal freedom and financial
opportunity around the world and at that
time the 250,000 Europeans that were in
the country were the smart ones were
thinking about making the chicken run so
the book flew off the shelves but of
course now there's probably less than a
thousand Europeans leptin and Bob way
I'm going back there in January I might
meet Mugabe it'll be a waste of time
he's an old guy soon to die but some of
the people under him might not be as
stupid and corrupt
I'll engage in my hobby again were you a
friend to be in Smiths no I never guy I
knew lots of people that knew him and I
never met him unfortunately water should
have would have could have but didn't
why do you think zimbabwe became what it
is today
well yeah because of a flawed philosophy
in other words as time goes on or went
on Mugabe became more and more corrupt
but he had the wrong philosophical
foundations he believed that the state
should do everything and it did the
state-controlled you know confiscated
all the land destroyed the curry in
other words Zimbabwe is Zimbabwe is 50
years ahead of where the u.s. is going
when you woke up this morning what was
the issue that was on your mind what
issue were you thinking about well the
next thing I'm going to do after we
finish this is listening to a debate
between Paul Krugman who's a political
hack disguised as an economist debating
Stephen Moore who's an actual economist
libertarian but since Krugman is much
more glib than Moore is I'm sure that
he'll be perceived to win the debate
he's a clever guy almost everything that
comes out of his mouth is usually not
just wrong but the opposite of the right
thing but he's fun to listen to and
clever so
I thought about that along with this
interview we're doing is being the
highlight of my day you have to give
Paul Krugman credit though for coming
here to Freedom Fest don't you I do but
I think his thing unlike most Nobel
Prize recipients is building the
cultists own personality so I suspect
that if you wave a camera and/or a crowd
in front of them he'll appear like a lap
dog anywhere from right on the money
people need to understand that cops are
not their friends the last thing you
want to do is have any contact with them
at all
yes this is not true of all cops of
course some cops are good guys but the
problem with the police is that many of
them maybe most of them for all I know
seem to have an extra Y chromosome they
are aggressive and cops today have a us
against them attitude it's us cops the
good guys against the potential
miscreants in society and increasingly
in the United States most cops are
ex-military and the military of course
is look is put on a pedestal but
actually the military is just a place
where you take orders from all kinds of
terrible people and follow them like a
robot so it's a culture of violence and
slavery as Gibbon said and most of the
cops today the younger ones are all
ex-military so no they're quite
dangerous once they put on that uniform
are we living in a police state these
days
oh I think we are we're moving in that
direction absolutely and as we speak
right now
here in the middle of 2015 we're I'd say
the financial clock is at about the same
place that it was in 2007 perhaps even
early 2008 and I expect the economy to
collapse and you recall how unpleasant
it was back in 2008 and this time things
are going to go off the edge much worse
and much different than they did in
2008-2009 these governments have been
creating trillions of new currency units
over the last several years and it's not
just the American government it's the
Chinese the Europeans the Japanese so I
think we're going to experience a very
very severe and long-lasting depression
characterized by inflation this time
around so what do we get together this
time next year we'll see if I'm right or
wrong it's long overdue in my opinion
quote from right on the money I do think
there is a very significant chance and
we are headed for something that might
vaguely resemble World War three yes and
this could happen and I don't know what
the catalyst could be you never really
know these things beforehand but what's
going on with Isis in Syria and Iraq to
my mind is perfectly predictable because
neither Syria nor Iraq are real
countries they're both artificial
constructs created arbitrarily in the
boardrooms of Europe well this is true
of all the countries in Africa all the
countries in the Middle East Central
Asia so Isis is not a very benevolent
organization but it's
in organic organization and was
predictable that's one possibility
what's going on in the Ukraine in the
eastern Ukraine with the next I'm all on
the side of the separatists they're
backed by the Russians but they have
every right to want to cut away from the
Ukraine which isn't it's like a it's
like a political intertidal zone it's
not a real country so it should break up
into at least two probably five or six
different political entities so those
are a couple places that things might
happen Saudi Arabia is a gigantic
accident just waiting to happen has been
waiting to explode for the last 30 years
so when Saudi Arabia blows up and breaks
up it would be interesting to see you
know but the problem is at this point
the US government is acting as agent
provocateur all around the world using
its military power which is about the
only part of the US government that kind
of works to make trouble
stick their noses into all kinds of
places where it doesn't belong so this
is not going to order a well especially
as the economy turns down the next time
because when things get bad economically
governments always look for somebody to
blame
it's those damn Chinese that caused this
problem they're making things too
cheaply if so then Saudis that are
causing this problem they're
manipulating the price of oil so this is
a good reason to or the Iranians are
they're the perpetual bete noire so I
think that probably the most dangerous
entity in the world today is actually
the US government
is it fair to say though that
libertarians forever have been saying
the sky is following the sky is falling
well sure I mean it depends on how you
want to look at a trend and how far back
you want to go after the Constitution
was put together in 1789 there's only
like three years later that the Congress
passed the Alien and Sedition Acts which
if they hadn't been repealed would have
already started to turn the u.s. into a
police state back then and then the War
Between the States which is incorrectly
called the Civil War because it was the
war of secession not a civil war where
the two entities were competing for the
same government did a lot of things and
the US has been going downhill from a
social point of view certainly since the
McKinley era when the u.s. conquered the
Philippines costing about 200,000
Filipino lives people forget that so
sure I mean everything it's look it's
the second law of thermodynamics
which basically is entropy and it states
that everything everything over time
devolves and falls apart and becomes
worse unless it has a substantial input
of outside energy so it happens to the
human body it happens to governments it
happens to countries sure so it's it's
all predictable we just don't know
exactly how long it's going to last but
I think that a hundred years from now on
the map on the wall showing the US will
have a different form than it currently
does and I question that the US will
even be one entity
Doug Casey this is from right on the
money ever since I was a teenager I
thought Christmas at least as practiced
in most of the West is a bad idea what
do you got to get into Christmas well
that's really a comment on Christianity
I grew up a Roman Catholic which I like
to joke was being a member of a
cannibalistic death cult but at this
point I'm I don't I don't believe in a
entity in the sky that we have to
worship and so I like the trappings of
Christmas you know but actually if
people took their religion seriously
which they shouldn't I don't think
unless you want to define religion as a
quest for a possible spiritual existence
which i think is interesting and you
should do because we might have a
spiritual existence very well might but
it's got nothing to do with these
commercial enterprises like all the
churches are today they're they're
they're corrupt they're
counterproductive and well I guess I go
on about religion and in a number of
actually the series of novels that I'm
writing which we get together next year
I hope we're talking about the next one
that's Speculator
and it takes an unjustly besmirched
occupation that of a speculator and
shows that you can be a very good guy
and be a speculator and
the sixth and final novel is when I can
do my thing on religion and it's called
Antichrist when our hero after having
been a warlord which is the fifth novel
comes back to the US because when when
you're a war a successful warlord they
think that he is God and if you're God
you have to give them a religion so our
hero comes back to the US and comes up
with a new religion to overthrow
Christianity and Islam and so forth so
I'm sure even more people will hate me
then than hate me now after that comes
out somebody picks up right on the money
what do you want them to take away from
this book take control of your own life
try to become rich because if you become
rich honestly you will only be able to
do so by providing goods and services
that other people want and making the
world a better place
so that's that's among other things what
that book is about Doug Casey is the
author right on the money is the name of
the book book TV on c-span 2 is on
location in Las Vegas at the annual
Freedom Fest
book TV is on Facebook like us to get
publishing news scheduling updates
behind-the-scenes pictures and videos
author information and to talk directly
with authors during our live programs
facebook.com slash book TV when you look
at the role that the Supreme Court is
playing in our society now our history
series have to have relevance and so as
we thought about what can we do to give
relevance to our current programming a
series on the court made all the sense
in the world
the court is an equal branch of
government
it's the third branch of government it
still has fundamental impact on
Americans lives inside this elegant
building is a courtroom where cases are
heard and decisions are made and impact
all of our lives there are so many
incredibly interesting cases in the
courts history we've all heard about Roe
vs. Wade we've heard about Brown versus
Board of Education but for so many
people they're just names in a textbook
and what we want to do is really talk
about that not only the legal side of
the cases but the people involved in
these cases they are human beings who
felt so passionately that they were
being wronged or the rights were being a
bridge that they brought their cases to
the court I think what people will find
most fascinating about these cases are
the personal stories one of my personal
favorites is mat versus Ohio in the
story of Dahl remap I think when people
hear this personal story of this woman
and the situation that they will fall in
love with these cases that they will
feel passionate about what happens in
the courts and why they matter and why
you should care picking the 12 cases was
a really difficult and arduous task it
was a fun task because we learned a lot
but those 12 cases represent really our
evolving understanding of rights in
America when you take a look from Dred
Scott to the Korematsu case to Miranda
all the way through Roe vs. Wade you
really do learn not only about the
history of the country but of a
evolving race in America landmark cases
historic Supreme Court decisions
produced in cooperation with the
National Constitution Center delving
into 12 Supreme Court cases that
significantly influenced our nation's
story and in our evolving understanding
of rights in America live Monday nights
at 9:00 p.m. Eastern beginning October
5th on c-span and c-span 3 and as a
companion to our new series landmark
cases the book it features the 12 cases
we've selected for the series with a
brief introduction into the background
highlights an impact of each case
written by veteran Supreme Court
journalist Tony Morrow published by
c-span in cooperation with congressional
quarterly press an imprint of sage
publications incorporated landmark cases
is available for 895 plus shipping and
handling
get your copy at c-span org slash
landmark cases next up on book TV in
primetime
airborne firefighter Jason Ramos talks
about his life as a smokejumper
and the changes in firefighting over the
past decade
now it is my pleasure to introduce our
author for tonight Jason Ramos Firestone
wildland fires are growing larger more
numerous scarier and more deadly every
year as mega drought conditions and the
increasing encroachment of development
into the wilderness have combined to
create a powder keg that threatens our
beautiful forests and even our lives
this topic is particularly poignant for
us as we have locally experienced
distressing devastations due to wildland
fires
jason has devoted almost 30 years of his
life to the fire service he progressed
from the streets of LA to his career
that began at the age of 17 as a
volunteer with the Riverside County Fire
Department then to wildland firefighting
in Southern California now a smokejumper
in his 16th season he is based in
Winthrop Washington at the North Cascade
smokejumper base the birthplace of smoke
jumping he is an awesomely good shape
take a look at him that can carry a pack
wakes significantly more than his entire
body weight soaking wet up steep terrain
for miles and miles
he loves gadgets widgets and gizmos and
as a mechanical engineer I resonate with
that and he founded product research
gear LLC USA describes USA Today
describes what he does is fighting fires
with brains and brawn fastened the
harness on your ground parachute and
prepare yourselves for a thrilling
evening with this truly exceptional
individual brought to you courtesy of
William Morrow an imprint of the
HarperCollins Publishers please join me
in welcoming Jason
[Applause]
my mic working hey folks how are you
Bruce is this set up I don't want to hit
a Murphy's Law and I'm a Mac guy so
you're you're testing me here now with
the so we're gonna watch a quick video
we're gonna do it for about five minutes
it's about twenty two minutes we're not
gonna do the full length but you guys
can go home and watch this on youtube or
on the web and it was done by Rick's to
her friend of mine he's a ex Air Force
Special Forces sere a gentleman
I shouldn't say Special Forces they they
don't like that so I'll just say Rick
Stewart and that's the voice narrating
the video so this was done about three
or four years ago at our base and it
just shows a glimpse of what we do
without the Hollywood most of time we
get approached by these big production
companies and they want a lot of oh and
all and most of the jumpers are very
quiet and reserved and kind of in a
corner
it's that better you want to hit plane
well we'll start this
please throw something at me if I'm not
loud enough and is that was that on
I went back to the beginning as I say
folks Murphy's Law is always on time so
we were here earlier prepping this and
you can see the amount of time just
sitting it kind of threw it back in the
pause mode presented without commercial
interruption by Smith & Wesson
question
she wonders
now that's that's a trailer yeah so you
need to go back out of that just go back
just go back to that first screen you
want to watch the feature just click
down to this okay yeah so folks if it
doesn't work we'll have everyone pull up
their phones you all can watch it by
yourselves and we'll talk in five
minutes
Owen and Patriot profiles presented
ended without commercial interruption by
Smith eNOS Hart
yep this is it this first part is a
little glitchy but it's the video
[Music]
it's not the uniform that defines the
warrior nor is that the accessories they
carry into battle not all warriors adorn
clothing and armor to deflect bullets or
to conceal the occupant for those who
can bat fire there's as a uniform to
deflect blows from branches and boulders
a uniform that protects the wearer's
from the flames range in the heat of a
different kind about
the fire like Mother Nature herself is a
thing of beauty
and yet a destructive unpredictable
force fire can save and or take them it
provides the blessings of light and heat
sense of security and signal a purifier
Forge and a host of other benefits to
mankind yet in its rage fires the
all-consuming dragon that destroys lives
property
without mercy
without prejudice
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
if you're going to jump from a perfectly
good airplane it's one thing to look for
flat ground in the perfect landing area
it's another to intentionally jump into
rugged mountainous terrain into the
proximity of a raging forest fire but
that is what these risk takers do in 92
I got flown in a helicopter fire which I
was pretty excited about and when I got
there there was this group of guys there
that had jumped in in parachutes and I
thought that was pretty unique a
smokejumper is not a gender or body type
it's a person of extreme physical
fitness high motivation and
unimpeachable work ethic
those that come to this colleague do so
with years of wildland firefighting
under their belt I didn't learn about
smoked up until around 1994 I mean
you're the idea but I never met a
smokejumper
on a fire and I finally met one and you
see this dis gentleman and you just kind
of stare at him that's a real solution
you know the allure is like a
professional sports league for the best
athletes advanced smoke jumpers are
those who have reached the pinnacle of
the wildland firefighting experience on
fires people know that smoke jumpers are
well versed highly motivated it's a
purpley train that was the first seed I
met a job out of Boise and out foot
that's what started my journey after
that it was I pushed it pushed you know
smokejumping it was just something that
was readily accessible to me
Dale longenecker says he knew he wanted
to be a smokejumper even before he
became a teenager I had two brothers
that jump before I did and actually
several cousins that were smoke jumpers
as well he started jumping in 1974 when
he was only 19 years old you know having
watched my brothers and cousins go
through Ricky training I was very
well-versed on what I needed to do it
requires a lot of know-how and physical
stamina to be a smokejumper
there is no experience in jumping
necessary you must um the trick in Walla
and fire what it's not gone you we don't
just hire City firemen say to LA City
with a couple years in he has to have
some type of wildland firefighting
experience and the minimum was one year
which equates to two seasons which is of
two to three years Reeves has been
smokejumping for five seasons
she completed rookie training in 2007
after three years as a wildland
firefighter in the case of rookie
training we can start with seven and and
with three or four it totally depends on
the batch of people but usually not
everybody who tries is gonna make it
well I tell you how after a person goes
through rookie smokejumper training it
can change how they look at the world
very acutely it's essentially the
overheads way of finding out exactly how
badly you want to be here a lot of
people liken it to boot camp every base
has a different training depends on the
trainer if he's a runner guys push-up
guy or the sit-up guy there is a
standard in that there are jumpers in
this profession thirty to forty years
old they can outrun and outperform most
of the younger and fittest candidates
that arrive for training there's a good
portion of it that's just purely
physical we have to be in good shape to
do this job so they want to make sure
that before they put the stamp of
approval on you you're faced with a
10-mile pack out in the wilderness
somewhere if you'll be able to get out
safely this is one things that do make
us different we're down the fire we have
all these things that we left this
aircraft with and we're not gonna leave
out in the fore so it's all gonna go
somewhere and it goes in a pack out bag
that's folder bully smaller left leg
pocket you got the pack out standards
you have to 210 pounds three miles in
there ninety minutes and that's a light
pack usually when you get on a fire it's
gonna be over that 100
800 you're lucky to get under 100 and
really lucky and then we'll move on to
your your jump operations and parachute
manipulations that's a huge part of our
job if you can't steer a parachute well
and get to the ground safely then nobody
wants to be on a plane if you we've had
some folks get to the door and on the
third or fourth fifth jump just decided
it wasn't for them there is a mental and
physical aspect of the training and
either or both will be reasons for
washing people from the program that's
what that four six weeks is to get as
much stress to that individual because
once you make the program once we exit
this aircraft
there's no one there - doesn't matter if
you have a sore throat or your pet fish
passed away you need to get that mission
done it get back to base if there is any
arrogance upon graduation from rookie
training it is quickly drummed out of
you by old heads and experienced jumpers
who know that since 1939 there's been a
very small and select group of jumpers
have gone before in fighting forest
fires time is precious even the fastest
combination of vehicle force and foot
travel permitted small fires to gain
momentum and become conflagrations
before they could be reached and
controlled then in 1940 came the
smokejumpers the dawn of smoke jumping
almost didn't even get off the ground
when a regional for okay folks we're
gonna stop it there so we can did you
guys like that so far though how was
that
so you can imagine the work that I had
to go through to get the approval of
someone to come to the base to have that
done that was days of me pulling my hair
I don't know how much hair as you can
see so I did have to do some smoke
screens and camouflage because we work
for the Forest Service and so there's
always rules those rules to blow your
nose there's rules to go to the bathroom
there's a rules had a user government
pen to fill out your times and you know
it's a smoke temple I work for you guys
I mean literally we work for the people
United States and to date there wasn't a
very good documentary out there and Rick
Stewart called me a friend of a friend
and he gave me his ward I find out his
background working for the Air Force and
he was like said friend of a friend and
I trust them and we made it happen so
there is please go home and watch the
the rest of that Rick Stewart is an
amazing man lives out of a Pacific
Northwest and just an amazing gentleman
that brought us this so hope you enjoyed
and hope you go home and watch the rest
of it in any questions so far I know we
have a mic up here but you know there's
so much to the program from 1939 to date
to get it all in an hour what I got is
crazy and I know there's a lot of
questions up there so we'll try to you
know get it all by the time you guys
leave today you'll kind understand what
we do is there any smokejumpers in the
audience you're tired smokejumpers don't
be hiding because I'm gonna find you -
all right where do you guys rookie from
where'd you rookie ready 70 - all right
yours born
and the the other gentleman Missoula all
right so two very faint we have night
smoker bases the United States reading
is a very hard base to rookie especially
with the triple digit temperatures
they're all hard all the bases have
rookie training and and I'm not gonna
lie to it's not easy was it easy for you
guys and that's usually the response we
get I had a friend of mine jumper he
always says Jason if you could have
anything the world anything right now to
go back and do Ricky training again what
do you want what is it and I gotcha so
yeah there's your brain just thinks back
to that and all you folks could do it's
all in your mind you all can do it just
depends how much stress and pain you
want to deal with to to do that but you
all have anemia so whether it be tennis
basketball sports it's all ingrained as
it depends how much you want to do that
in the program that four to six weeks is
a test of that so I'm gonna test you
every single day from that four to six
weeks being a rookie I remember one of
the things that would kind of hurt you a
little bit every day there was a trainer
not every day but mostly every other day
he would say give you guys you know a
round of applause you made it today but
you know might not be here tomorrow have
a good night
and I say you
we're gonna keep it pg-13 but yeah it
was like I want to take this guy so and
he was right though that you might not
be there the next day and they bring
that reality back to you're not
guaranteed that position
it's a privilege it's not an honor
you're not guaranteed to become a United
States smokejumper so that really you
know okay and then you learn to take
stuff minute by minute day by day and
that was my you know day at the showers
I go it I mean today we'll see what
happens tomorrow it might not be here so
any questions so far on that before we
move on smokejumpers in the united
states it's a very dynamic number as we
talked just think very dynamic so since
1939 today would have to look at the
roster what we're still under 6,000
i doubt we won over 6,000 because last
year we were like 5,800 almost nine and
do we need I don't think we had that
many of Rockies out of those bases I had
a new mic test test that better alright
now I can move can I clip this maybe
this is a room back there I can't see
there we go alright that makes me happy
so less than 6,000 since 1939 to date
those are bonafide smoke to them so the
true gentleman back there I can grab
their names go on my phone
pull the database and I can see where
they rookie did what year what basis
tells me everything if they're legit and
they are but that's there's not many of
us so we have a database to show and
it's a proud thing to show the grandkids
and my dad or grandpa was there my
grandma was a smokejumper so to date
through the fire season other nine bases
were round again a very fluctuating
number I don't believe it's over 500 in
that we have high school teachers
professors at our base we had to pair
rescue PJ's out of the Air Force we've
had ex-ranger so these folks are coming
and going throughout the season some of
these folks come
for there they caught therefore their
summer vacation to come back to come
back to duty which that's not my thing
of occasion but some of the high school
teachers I mean they'd love to come back
and these guys are remember where the
jumpers this year he's a high school
teacher I believe he's 54 and he ran a
mana 1/2 and just under 9 minutes 30
seconds the guys still savage I mean he
this this their that's what these folks
are they're very motivated and they
don't accept anything else and it's
amazing to see a guy you know you know
late 50s go out there and pass a 20 year
or 25 year old their 26 year old and go
out and pump out 20 pull-ups and not
even sweat not even breathe hard and
smile at you and then as he's walking
away to tell you how old he is you know
say thank thank you so and in that you
know I never classified smoked German
smoked I've never classified mayor fema
I just call them smoke jumpers but a lot
you asked how many females they say
there's less than 8 percent I don't know
we'd have to count to me their smoke
jumpers they all have to pass the same
physical fitness we don't have special
pull-ups or sit-ups or runs we have no
handicap in that four to six weeks for
gender color race I don't care if you
got in tennis coming out of here and
you're purple you got to do the same
tests so once they pass those females
those males will be female and she's
very pretty we get tours throughout the
base and it's funny people come to a
point is that person back there a
smokejumper I said oh you mean someone
so I said yeah she is
so very interesting like I said four to
six weeks I'm tell you it's not it
wasn't easy how was your rookie training
back in 72 sir
there you go so again they're looking
for those folks when when you complete
the program you're done you get on that
jump list that tells us who's going for
that day if we get a fire and how many
people are on this plane or two planes
once you pass that program you can go
anywhere in the United States so it's
the major leagues we call it or the NFL
whatever you want to call it there's no
more captain there's no more lieutenant
telling you to tie your shoelaces wipe
your nose blow your nose eat lunch did
you take your medicine today in the
smokejumper world now you are fully
self-contained United's a smokejumper so
know when they say you complete your
program at all now you're on that jump
list and the siren goes off you can go
anywhere in the United States which is
pretty interesting at times so we have
nine smokejumper bases from California
Redmond OR Oregon Winthrop Washington
Alaska Fairbanks Missoula Montana
Grangeville Idaho
I'll call Idaho a West Yellowstone and
I'm missing one Boise I believe that's
nine and then at those nine bases we can
do a satellite base so we can make a
smokejumper base anywhere in the United
States so if there's a bunch of
lightning another state so you guys all
heard storm chasers right so basically
that's kind of what we are so if you
have a bunch of lightning in a certain
state we might pre position a jump plane
and ten jumpers or a load or thirty
jumpers to sit there for X amount of
time to help with those fires that that
lightly might cause so again a very
dynamic
how would you say we're a very unique
thing dying at yeah we have we have a
lot of that so we can get a cassette and
during training it's some of the
training you know training so you go do
this I'll change your mind you go back
and do something else and they're
teaching to be very flexible because
even in the fire service you might be
going one way guys ever been around a
fire engine needs got his lights on us
and the lights turned off and then you
see him turn on go somewhere else and
he's got his lights back on
he's got Reed diverted to another call
like us sometimes we might fly to search
state and turn around to fly somewhere
else sometimes you might think in your
do a 10-minute flight and you fall
asleep and now you're in another state
you look out the window sue they say
Washington this is a Washington this is
a question I don't like so it's the old
the program was designed to get the
highest trained firefighters to an
incident and fix it problem solvers put
the fire out
nowaday we do search and rescue if we
get called by the local the Sheriff's
Department we can do escort missions
I've been inserted of a helicopter go
find hikers and meet and greet them and
take them out of an area because there's
a fire coming and that's hard getting
them drop out the middle nowhere no
Intel I got a GPS that's barely working
because the trees are so tall and I'm
supposed to find this trail and find
three people in a very big area so we
found a Mary thing hurt so we do a lot
of special I promise offers again so
when we get dropped off we have the food
we have the water we have training to be
by ourselves and to do things that most
folks don't want to do that again that's
in the in the training so the dispatch
it depends on what state you're in it
could come from a lookout tower that
reported a fire it can be from Alaska
flight 682 going to Alaska that calls it
in it'll go to dispatch they'll have it
on the map if that fire is not reported
they'll go through the no-go checklist
whatever that state or dispatches
and then it'll get routed to us and once
we get the call we'll be off the ground
at our base under ten minutes so it's
quick it's very quick so it just depends
again where that calls coming from
there's a test at the end I can walk do
you like it I can walk okay good you
have the main training what happens each
year do you have to re-qualify I mean
yes no we're not going we're not going
to go through the four to six weeks but
we are going to do our physical we have
to do a run some bases are now
implementing the pack out 110 through
miles under 90 minutes which we have to
do in rookie training so we do have to
wreak Walla Phi we call it running for
your job or so you do have to recall to
come back to be on the load so I do have
an injury that I got back in 2013 and
I'm not what we call it jump duty
arduous fire duty but I can't jump out
of the plane yet due to my injury until
the doctor says yeah you're not going to
be any shorter mess up your back anymore
so those are the protocols so I have to
literally there's no special treatment
you could be the CEO of the base with 30
years in and if you can't pass you can't
pass
yup so no special treatment for anyone
sure the the protocol for wildfires now
is if it started naturally let it burn
what's the decision-making process that
tells you guys go or no-go for a
particular fire so folks what are you
talking about there is some there are
some states what we call a let burn
policy or no go checklist what not those
areas would be always see in wilderness
areas and that's all pre-planned within
those states in those districts to make
it kind of makes sense so it just again
it depends on where that is at if it's
out in the wilderness or whatnot yeah we
want mother nature take its course we
want her to clean up all that stuff
that's been growing for years and years
and years and years so it just depends
where that's at if it's near homes life
and property no we're not letting that
burn a lot of people's before you guys
let me letting that fire happen and the
mission I just did about two weeks ago I
was many different roles for 14 days and
one of them was a public information
officer and that is a hard job you can
imagine and I don't have you can imagine
people coming up and yelling at ya and
they don't have the right picture and
it's funny because you see a fire behind
you and you see all this stuff but you
don't see anything happening and then
when I explained them - sir we have a
hotshot crew 20 people here we have
lookouts here we have a helicopter that
just dropped that you missed we have a
jumper here you have all these people
right now there's 600 so many people on
this really so it's it's so much that
very dynamic that's happening but that
policy yes it's it's a hard one and I
think in certain just my opinion if it's
places out there where it cannot get to
life and property let mother nature take
its course that is my personal opinion
for that their fire is good when he gets
so much debt growth and then if she
comes very mad has anyone read my book
yet
you can hear some of it so sometimes I
call her I call her her
she gets very pissed and that's the bad
fire when you get a lot of debt and down
I call it trash and that makes a lot of
energy and that's what ruins stuff that
can I mean we're talking stuff doesn't
grow for a long time because it's so hot
you're over 2,000 degrees now so that's
the bad fire we don't want it to get
that big so any other questions so far
folks I'm curious about how you work
with the incident commands because of
course when a fire starts often in this
state it can be the sheriff that is
correct
overseeing it and how do you get in
there quickly when a fire has great
potential but the incident command has
perhaps not gone to the federal level
how do you actually liaison with those
kinds of situations okay
so folks you talking about into the
command system a good example is we've
all seen hurricanes floods match
disasters 9/11 that was under the
incident command system basically the
four surest we're very good at natural
disasters not just fires lucky what does
foresters doing here say this is what we
do so still today we train folks from
New York City the last mission I had we
had two guys from Hawaii come on why are
you firefighters what are they doing
here they're part of the incident
command system that goes to these big
incidents not just the United States
we're talking around the world
here's remember a few years back Israel
had a big issue of fires some people
were killed
you guys remember that was around
Christmastime so that that country hit
the panic button went to United States
and within a few hours you really had
jumpers in Boise our base already staged
and again on a commercial flight to fly
to Israel some folk we never got that
far but some folks ambassadors from the
US did get to Israel and help out that's
how fast we can mobilize which is blow
your mind so when we take that very
seriously so the incident command system
on our levels initial attack
smokejumpers we're not under that large
in the command system yet to us yet to
us that's big incidents so we get there
we have our own in
command and a bunch of funny acronyms
folks ICT fives fours threes Task Force
leaders division all these different
things that I'm qualified to handle
under my span of control of a fire and
every jumpers going to have plus or
minus of those training qualifications
today in a smokejumper